2004 I became a millionaire from and
selling sneakers so explain how you made
a million dollars selling sneakers 2002
I got a marketing job with Nike I
started to collect sneakers I had a
fallen out with Nike my shoe was
supposed to come out it was going to be
a Nike Terminator I was super excited
didn't work out didn't happen I said I
didn't wear Nikes for eight years I end
up selling all the shoes they gave me
all the shoes I collected but 1800 pairs
of sneakers it was like 3.2 million
dollars so you bought a Ferrari yeah
Ferrari about a 360 challenge to Dolly
oh no way and that's must have been when
the car just came out just came out
I love that